[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world of random
bends with the role of one dice
this is the story of a magical kingdom
you're listening to ko city pirate radio
to welcome all you new brawlers out
there but what if i told you
there is
look at these dogs i almost forgot they
used to be humans
why'd you look like a flood of play
wanna change back what then you need to
fix
your relationship i
[Music]
no okay
[Music]
they should be scared of us
hi i'm todd martens a gaming journalist
for the los angeles times and welcome to
the ea spotlight series
this is the second panel in which ea is
connecting you
with the games you love and the people
who make them leading up to ea play on
july 22nd ea invited me to chat with a
number of their independent studios that
are under the ea originals banner
i was happy to do this a lot of the
games in independent space are some of
my
favorite games they are games that tend
to innovate both technologically and on
the storytelling front
ea originals was founded in 2015 with
the mission statement to
find cultivate build successful
partnerships with some of the world's
leading independent studios
the first game under the ea regionals
banner i believe was unravel from
coldwood studios
it was one of my favorite games of that
year a number of these games have been
recognized by the baftas and other
industry organizations
so with that let's dig into the panel
and
meet some of the most thoughtful voices
in the independent gaming space today
who are working on projects under the ea
originals banner
thank you everyone for joining us i'm
super excited to talk to all of you i
think we've got kind of a cool
range of voices a different sort of some
different ideas
i just figured we'd do a real quick
intro of just
say your name and uh give a quick
thought of your sort of non-game
background
as well and then just real quickly say
the first game you ever fell in love
with
so uh joseph i'll throw it over to you
yes
my name is joseph harris and i'm the
creative
director and founder at hazelite pretty
much
i have actually a background in films
i've done
five or six fishing movies i've been
working with movies pretty much for 10
years
and started making games for 10 years
ago
and my first game i fell in love with
have to be super mario bros
1 even if i played actually started
playing earlier with the atari one
uh well it's a classic and probably one
of the greatest first levels of all time
um olav uh let's hear a little bit from
you
and uh over at zoink and some of the
maybe non-game stuff you've
dabbled in uh yeah hi i'm ula riad malm
and i'm the creative director and the
writer on lost in random
and well my first big
love within video games was baldur's
gate with its huge story
and the possibility of creating your own
story in in that
world and i think i learned english
playing that game too so and originally
i'm a comic artist and
a storyboarder when i started working
with games that's how i
got my foot in there with drawing my
ideas explaining quickly with with
fast drawings um so let's jump over to
uh our team from
silver rain studios uh so there's a new
studio
and while we're not here to necessarily
talk about the game you guys have
um abu sort of talk a little bit about
uh your background
and um starting uh this studio
yeah hi um my name is abubakar salim
um the creative director of our
undisclosed game
at silver ring games originally actor um
also done producing as well within the
film industry and the tv industry
um but yeah decided to get into games
because i mean i love games
one game that i fell in love with the
sonic the hedgehog on the sega that's a
pretty slick game
hi i'm melissa phillips i'm head of
studio at silver rain games
a studio that started we launched in
march 2020 last year
i have backgrounds in both music and
psychology i've got degrees in those
of which i weirdly use none of them
but all of them every single day in my
job
and first game that i really loved and
brought me into games was probably all
either theme hospital or populist the
beginning
awesome and guha uh congrats on the
launch of
knockout city uh pretty recently this
year so you have a pretty wide ranging
background
as well um i think a lot of people know
some of your background in the tech side
of games but
uh yeah just give us a quick sort of
intro on um
you know your world and your expertise
and um the first game you fell in love
with uh thank you todd
it's funny if i talk about my non-games
background it's really going to very
early childhood you know karthik my
brother and i started
uh our first game company vicarious
visions when we were in high school i
was 14 and he was 15 and basically
that was all about learning how to make
a video game and we it's
um you know while we played many video
games
uh the actual process of peeling back
how you construct
it every aspect of the creative process
playing all the roles
when there are no instruction books on
how to do it that was just so
fascinating and continues to drive us
and so with vellum studios our mission
is really to find those new types of
interactivity
that the people that are really
unexpected people really wonder where
they come from and you really need to
get your hands on them
uh to be able to understand that now
back in the day what really got me
interested
was a game called starfly 2. actually i
played star flight 1 after stu it was a
pc game uh ms-dos at the time
but it just showed with even limited
technology
you really open the imagination and make
non-linear narrative where you really
put the
player as the hero and as the center of
an adventure
in the center of progression and that
unlocks so much for us
so i don't want to put the uh the new
studio on the spot
but um i guess i'm gonna do that a
little bit um abu
uh just talk a little bit about you know
you said you've loved games but your
decision to
you know really want to express that
love by starting a studio
um you know the journey from starting
that studio to
working with ea originals um and we'll
start there
yeah no i think look i mean i i think
there's a lot of um
power in storytelling in games because i
feel like
you've got the audience playing it and
interacting with the characters on the
screen
or you know really kind of shaping the
story that's going on or you get them in
that journey they're
they're in their shoes the way i kind of
see it is like i'm a storyteller by
heart right so
it's just another way or another voice
or another platform
to tell those stories on it's it's a
great journey because we're just all a
bunch of kids
wanting to play storytellers right and
um
yeah that's what it is it's funny isn't
it we have um
between us we've got a number of years
in the games industry
um and we knew a lot about playing games
and how games were made and the people
behind them
but actually being on the other side now
uh it's been a whole
learning experience the last year has
been a baptism of fire i guess as we
uh make mistakes but we we learn from
them and
i think that's what's really lovely
about the studio with silver rain is
that
we really value the team that we have
it's an incredible team
uh just over 30 people now um and still
growing
we've always got jobs on the website if
anyone wants to check that out starting
big man 30 people already damn
i remember it's one of our learnings
30 people over here yeah yeah i remember
when i did brothers we were like uh
we were 10 people not eight or nine
people you start big
now i just want to add something to that
because i have a bit kind of the same
background from a movie i just want to
make something clear to add a little bit
what you were talking about
for me these two are two entirely
different mediums it's very important to
remember that
because uh one is interactive and one is
passive
because one thing i've learned is that
games are not movies and i think
sometimes it's the opposite
when you when you like uh want to make a
game that's closer to a movie there are
two entirely different uh
mediums you could get inspired from each
other but the way for instance to write
a book or to write a script
a screenplay are two entirely different
ways of writing stuff
and this is what we need to do for for a
game as well so i'm a super optimist
in impactful stories and i mean
emotional impacts on on people in the
future well we're just there
we're we're just like scratching the
surface you know uh we had a
dark period in games and it occurred
between like 2000 approximately in 2010
but there was a notion among companies
that you would see the film
and then play the game as if the
interactivity would be the same as a
linear medium
and you try to capture empathy like
affection
and love and drama and tension between a
boy and a girl
but with mechanics like shooting and
action
and there would be a total mismatch and
this is sort of the big downfall of
narrative experiences of the past
it makes a lot of sense also to tell to
tell the story in video games because
you're always following you like the
interactivity you're always
looking at the step-by-step experience
of the player and like really immersing
yourself in what will they actually
experience what will they see
and and what will they feel and and for
me that makes so much
sense to tell a story in video games
because
yeah you're really putting yourself in a
situation in a different way i think and
and it's helped me a lot to to learn
about writing scripts as well like
longer scripts because you have to fill
in the in the details you can't
leave anything to the imagination uh
until
until it's in the player's hands yeah
why'd you look like a
blob of clay wanna change back then you
need to fix
your relationship you know um it takes
two
uh joseph is a really fascinating game
to me um
it deals with a lot of grown-up topics
yet at times it feels very silly very
wacky
and at times the gameplay almost feels
like a metaphor of this couple's
relationship
so i just talk about you know sort of
the challenge of telling what is
you know what on the surface is a very
sort of you know classic story about a
couple
um but then making that come through
ver via the actions you're taking in the
game yeah for sure i mean that's what we
at hayes light are focusing a lot on
like trying to use the mechanics as part
of the storytelling
and you don't want to end up in a
situation where you play a game
i mean you could play some games
sometimes we're almost waiting for the
next cutscene so the idea is to use it
the mechanics as part of the story i
think it's a little bit underused in
gaming now and i think we can use it way
more often i mean it takes two you have
many situations
sometimes we use in a metaphorical way
for
there's a level where the characters are
working on their attraction as couples
and then we we give them magnets just
kind of a
as a metaphoric way for them to both
play that and have it in the story
and but also it could be that you know
whatever they meet if they meet
like a hammer from a toolbox that they
own or something you're actually playing
so you're playing what you're seeing and
immediately you use the mechanics as
part of the story time you could also
use the mechanics
in a sense to convince an emotion for
the player i mean for instance
the first game i did brothers you i mean
i'm gonna spoil it a little bit if if
someone haven't played it but in the end
you're actually
literally like a playing uh like like
burying your big big brother that dies
in the end a little bit so
it's almost and i would say the opening
of last of us where you carry your girl
and runs with her like everything like
you're using the mechanic to to to push
your storytelling and that is a bit
underused sometimes and i think we can
push that even more and that's what
we are hazel i want to keep pushing
the world of random bends with the role
of one dice
olaf um lost in random looks uh
beautiful
thank you curious to hear you talk a
little bit about
and let's sort of you know people
watching know sort of about
the tone of that game you know the big
picture sort of tone of that game
but also how that sort of pairs
with you know the gameplay and you know
the quote-unquote randomness that you
guys are trying
to sort of come about in how we play
that game
yeah in in lost in random so it's it's a
dark fairy tale
it's an action adventure and you play as
this girl who grows up in
in this uh there are three wards in the
land of random
one word for each side of a six-sided
dice and this dies belong to
an evil queen of course and and she
she rules she creates this weird systems
to keep these places in check and so
every world has its own theme
when we first started with the project
we wanted to do something darker
so a fairy tale that was a little bit
darker than the rest of the stuff we'd
already made
and we tried out drawing all these
different characters and concepts and
but it wasn't until this painting of of
a dice
and her girl appeared that we knew that
there is something to explore the
concept of a living dice
as a companion of of the protagonist was
attractive to us another scary thing was
what would the gameplay be like what is
too random and
what is just random enough everything
revolves around the dice and grows out
of this dice
the theme and the gameplay so it's been
a great
concept very natural to like
everything's grown very natural out of
it
and it's so important to to like if you
have it ever i have an idea that is
weird and
and you're uncertain of it at first and
it hasn't been done before you don't
have a reference game
you need people you need to ask people
for a bit of faith to stick with the
idea and just stay with it and okay
we're not sure what what it will be and
but it's important to let yourself to be
very i don't know
let's not know together for a while and
explore this uh weird idea and see where
it goes
i was just going to add in actually
everything that everybody said is
is just lovely and it's exactly why i
love working in games
and what makes the games industry really
special
my fear and actually something to
perhaps pose back to the group is that
i always worry about whether we can hold
on to this authenticity
as a as an industry uh because the more
interested
that uh business and other industries
become in us
uh the more at risk we are of losing
that authenticity i think we're having a
sort of golden age at the moment where
this freedom is allowed and
people like myself can start to see
themselves coming through in these
stories
and i i hope that we can keep that alive
and keep that going and that that
authenticity isn't lost
or merged into other industries
you know i think that's exactly why
we're in these studios because
that authenticity is worth the struggle
it's worth fighting for
and it takes an independent mindset
to really push the boundaries uh to be
able to take the risk
to come out of a typical business model
or a typical franchise stream to create
a unique emotional experience for
players
and we have we've made active choices to
have that flexibility
and it comes along with it some kind of
burden as well it's not as predictable
it's not as bankable it's uh
you know you know a lot of the risks
meet with failure and that has to be
learning experience
and that sounds a little trite but every
indie game cycle involves that
i wouldn't to be too worried actually to
have
i think if you have a uh
when you have a strong vision what you
believe in i think actually it's the
opposite the other industries around us
i mean
if you look at the movies if we're
talking about that uh
they will soon realize how great
storytelling is in gaming and
actually are realizing that sometimes if
that's yeah
don't worry there's nothing to fear here
there will come i know the movie
business they will come crawling and
understand how beautiful gaming is
now at the end of the day it's all about
like uh you know
impacting and touching people's hearts
here
i wanted to sort of bring it up with you
with uh knockout city because
when people talk about that game that
game isn't necessarily a quote-unquote a
narrative game um
it is a a sport um you know dodgeball
inspired
um you know but at the same time when i
played that game the first thing that
struck me was the
emotion of that game um like the tone of
that game the way it looked the way it
felt it was very bright it was
extending a hand to the player it felt
very welcoming
um you know but and we don't necessarily
put that up front when we talk about
games we talk about it as
as a dodgeball as a mechanic as a you do
this you fight this you
xyz we don't necessarily talk about the
uh emotion
uh you know it's a great uh great point
and it's actually one of the ways that
we center
uh discovery at valence studios which is
when we create
um some something that feels like the
core
of something new a game worth making
we try to ask the question how do you
feel and when we found this kind of
throwing and catching you know just
imagine you know when we were playing
throwing and catching you know some of
us do i do it all the time with my
children for example
but you know through childhood it's one
of the universal narratives
when you do throwing and catching and
special things with it in all sports
it makes you feel energetic it energizes
you it's a joy when you catch the tough
past
and so we said okay this is the start of
something joyful competition
we don't see that in games that much
let's build on that and then the world
gives us the grounding
knockout city we invented it as a place
to say how do we experience this joyful
competition
a world that's sort of the way we
imagine it
should be inclusive welcoming uh
everything is settled with epic
dodgeball battles that make it so
even if you're outgunned and outnumbered
with your skill
you can actually make a difference but
then
even if you get defeated you're ready to
get back into it because you feel like
you weren't
beaten you feel like you're ready to be
back in the competition so we start with
that emotional profile
all the decisions from a design
standpoint from a world building
standpoint
from music design standpoint uh come
from that
we even have some backstory to make sure
that the and we don't explicitly do it
we don't use narrative techniques but
it's in the world
and it's in the vo uh it's to be able to
make people feel like they're grounded
in this and they can be part of that
experience so
we start with mechanics at a core that
feel novel interesting
compelling but really they're only
successful if they elicit
some kind of novel emotional response
that says i'm here to play
with my friends and feel something
different so we use different techniques
and narrative
to be able to achieve that and abu i was
kind of curious to
hear your thoughts a little bit just
we've talked to you in the last few
minutes about some like high level
topics about
emotion in games and marrying gameplay
and story
um and just sort of coming at this from
a new studio i know we're all curious to
hear what you're working on when you're
ready to
talk about it but what would you sort of
say like
what would be maybe like a thesis for
the studio in terms of
where you guys want to put a focus yeah
i mean look it does start with story
right and it starts
with with it starts there but it's
quickly followed by
again the medium in which you're telling
it which is interactivity
i think you know for us as well it's
we're always we're always asking
about that player's journey about that
players experience and that's why
it's funny whenever i whenever we talk
about the idea of like you know emotion
and games and stuff
like that like i i don't think that
that's not the aim man like the aim is
to just
is to deliver a brilliant experience
like you don't go to the theater to go
and
you know watch a play which is supposed
to be sad oh you go watch a good play
if it's sad and it's happy that's
fantastic and um
and it's it look in it's it's a it's
tough man like
making games isn't easy it's it's it's
hard hard process but
that's what's so brilliant and beautiful
about it because
i i truly believe that through the
through the difficulty of finding
something and hitting it right
you end up basically sharing that
difficulty
and that hard you know that hard journey
with the person playing it they feel
that and they
are able to experience that with you i
was just going to add in as well
and here's the kicker like ideas are
cheap everybody has ideas
um my mom has ideas my dog has ideas
i have ideas you know we are a team
where everybody has the capability
of being creative in some way
the hard part i think of game making is
how do we
choose which ideas we take forward out
of this
mad pool of ideas that we have
and i think the craft comes from being
able to
select the best sometimes just the most
feasible ideas not even the best we
sometimes have to
kill some fantastic ideas but
the game making process is about how do
we prioritize what goes forwards what
feels good
and the craft comes from actually making
those ideas
and and testing them and iterating on
them and making sure that
all of that comes together to create the
game when i was playing
it takes two i went into that game you
know
the pandemic was still very much mystery
here in america at that time
and then there was the other idea of
like i was also going through a
relationship that was falling apart
so i didn't necessarily i was nervous
about playing
it takes two because i was like do i
want to play a game about a divorce at
the same time like that game is so
silly and fun and inventive like i never
once felt necessarily quote unquote sad
i just felt
exuberance at like learning about these
characters
someone asked me like uh is this kind of
a relation
you know shift uh to help you it's kind
of kind of a therapy session or
something
the funny part is that we saw already in
the testing already when playing the
game that
if you're in a relationship that wasn't
so good it was quite clear actually
because you really had to
you know it's almost like the experience
are in the couch that's almost also how
we design the game so
if you if you're playing this with your
partner and your communication is not
right
then you're not going to be able to play
the game that good so not only will you
will the game be you know not go have
the same fluidness in the game you will
also
may say something about your own
relationship that something is not
working
and from that perspective we're seeing i
mean reactions today
i don't know how accurate or true they
are of people actually
you know asking each other to get
married after the game and stuff like
that
and that's quite cool actually if it's
true i don't know but that's how they
write to us i have to accept that it
is a true thing but it's a good way to
get to know like
where you are at in your relationship
because obviously communication is key
i mean yes it takes two it takes you to
communicate as well
guha i wanted to sort of transition a
little bit and
hear your thoughts on with sort of a
game like knockout city which is going
to be an ongoing game and is going to
evolve
you know you and the team are maybe
thinking about adding some story
but keeping that sort of lively and
keeping that constantly sort of fresh
um and and the way you know game studio
can experiment
with a live service game in ways that
you know we don't get in
other other mediums you know um todd the
um
mindset for us always was let's get the
game out
and then see how the community responds
and embraces it and then evolve it with
the community
and so from the very early onset it was
designed as a sort of live service
product which
finds an audience and then follows the
audience and evolves it and continues to
surprise
so we have a slew of content that's
actually in production that will be
available
and the idea is surprise them
with new things that can change up the
play now we'll have evolution of the
hideout which is your
interactive social lobby where you team
up with friends uh before you get into a
game
instead of waiting at a menu to be able
to find out if they show up and
you know that kind of thing and so it
was really interesting you know the
early prototypes of knockout today
started um in 2017 so
a little over four years before it was
launched that's a long
longish cycle for a game but it feels
like we're
still at the starting uh line you know
the launch is the star
you know there's this conversation
always in pop culture amongst fans and
amongst creators that it's like
everything has to be based on ip um and
in the independent game world
this is where all of like originality is
um you know and i was kind of curious
olaf to hear
you know you talk a little bit about the
studio and deciding
on lost and random and like what was the
sense of
you know because as melissa was saying
earlier like everybody has ideas
so what was the sense of like this is
something that we can experiment with
both as a studio that we can experiment
with
as artists but something we feel good
about you know committing
you know x amount of years of our lives
too me personally
of course there's great value in looking
at the market and what
people are playing right now but people
won't be playing what they are now
in a couple of years so why not just go
with what's fun
and weird in the moment it's it's a it's
a very art
driven studio always has been zoink uh
driven by klaus lingalad who's now the
head of the
development and he's usually the guy
like well we're sweating and
finishing the previous game he's like
guys what do you think about a giant
ghost in vr and we're like yeah we got
to finish this thing first but sounds
great give us some time and and digest
it abu already said also we're all
just kids playing like like oh then this
guy comes and he he fights this guy and
they're
they're brothers actually and why like
that kind of energy you want to bring to
to creating video games i think
so yeah just just uh go with that
creative
joy and and for us it started out with
wanting to try out something darker like
i always said than our
longing for a fantasy and a saga and you
know we looked at grim fairy tales and
over the garden wall and stuff like that
and even if the idea at first
makes everyone go ah really
hmm okay dice with legs and arms and
okay let's taste it for a bit and and
like don't be afraid of the kind of
worms
yeah i guess it's the message yeah just
wanted to say like
that is actually a perfect um sort of
analogy in the way of what
the originals like team do in regards of
like
they're not afraid to take a risk like
you can you will come in with a crazy
idea and you'll come in with something
quite quite out there something that's
not really necessarily been seen or
sounds
dangerous or sounds hard and they will
be like you know what
go for it they give you that space and
room to play which is so
so beautiful and rare to see in
in a lot of spaces in the arts like like
look i'm i'm doing a show at the moment
out here called raised by wolves and the
first two episodes of the season
thanks they were great the first i've
been waiting thank you very much
sorry thank you well no but like look
the first two episodes right
were directed by ridley scott and it's
it's terrifying
right it's one of those things where
it's like you you're
you're going head-to-head with this
goliath right but
the beauty of what he was able to
capture on set was he
allowed you room to play he allowed your
room to be bold he allowed you room to
just
explore which is so rare sometimes
i think every publisher should do this
actually focus
on creative crazy games that does
something very different
but doesn't have the major financial
risk because i understand like you want
to put a hundred million dollars
something that's crazy risky
however though those smaller games are
crazy and more creative adventure
you can actually see stuff functioning
and working and then you can actually
inspire the triple a
also as well you know joseph i want to
um yeah look at that and say you know
it's not just about inspiring triple a
it's about saying
you know all new novel concepts can
start small
you know it's the kind of the simple as
a hard concept hey
you know when we wrote our if you write
the concept for knockout city on a piece
of paper people will be like
i'm gonna play this action game with
dodge balls uh give me a gun i think i
know how to do that
um and so that's typically the response
for that
but the concept itself can be proven out
at a small scale
and the concept itself can grow and it
can be grown
by the same by you joseph in your
context by us
from a knockout city standpoint but it's
the ability to recognize that something
special
both the developer recognizes but then
also you know the label should recognize
as well
and believe in one of the things that
was most impressive to us was that um
after we had found this core and you
know we thought hey this
this is a good game i'm feeling what i
need to feel with this thing
we shopped it around and there's
something unique about the
original team and ea everybody played
everybody all the way to the executive
uh team at the a played before we said
huh that's the right partner for us
because they could understand that
vision they could see it and they said
okay we're ready to take a risk not a
huge risk
but we're ready to take a risk and
series of sequential bats because this
game
needs to come out well and knockout city
was also kind of a
risk for the studio as well like you
guys had to create
uh pretty much a new a new game engine
for this project
yeah i mean there was uh nothing like it
before and there's a good reason
it's really hard to do a mechanic that's
purely based on throwing and catching
essentially physics based gameplay in a
competitive setting where there are many
physics objects the player him
or herself could be themselves become
the ball
uh that there's a ever changing map
landscape with dynamic maps
and uh fundamentally relies on the
interactivity between the team
throwing cat passing catching when you
have a player on the east and west coast
or
east coast and then in europe playing
together or playing against each other
it's an incredibly hard problem to solve
and we couldn't find conventional
approaches to do it
so we had to invent the computer
language to be able to
allow us to do reversible computation at
scale and that's pretty much how we
approach problem solving here available
it's sort of like
you know if this game needs to be made
we're going to figure out how to do it
i just want to add on even if we're
working with unreal
you know but let me tell you this the
amount of stuff we added on to make an
online game also function in split
screen with so much variety in game
mechanics it's absolute
madness actually i know that we made
more
tools that unreal are using from us than
we are using from them so in a sense we
created our own this
i mean it's a huge challenge to create a
an online game i mean not not
i mean especially in split screen where
you see the lag and everything so
there's
i think i think whoever has an engine
you you need to do a lot of add-ons that
fits your vision and game
like you're saying yeah yeah i know i
was curious joseph um
if being an indie studio if you felt
that that made that task
of having to sort of invent those tools
even using a popular game engine and
just being independent if that made it
you know easier for you guys like as a
studio to sort of
shift directions at whims or because it
seems like it is a very big of a mission
statement for your studio to
do sort of co-op sort of games i
wouldn't call us
in the india right now i would say we
are a bit we are more a triple i
as they say today not not just a regular
indie so we have
more knowledge our developers are more
like you know
a more kickas they know more how to do
stuff we know more how to solve stuff
we've done it before
so we have the tools to do it uh way
better before but
but of course it's always a risk
especially
the games we do because every game we do
is is something totally different
obviously you have
co-op and story that is common to what
we do but the world
the characters the gameplay everything
is totally different in the next game
let me tell you it would blow people's
mind actually
um i'm ready to hear about it but
are you really are you ready can you
handle it that's what i'm telling you
man
next game will be like what uh these
guys have really lost their minds
i mean totally in a good way bring it on
you know we touch on a lot of different
topics uh today
and you know just on the subject of
being an independent studio
and the ways an independent studio can
innovate in maybe ways other studios
can't
um just kind of wanted like a real quick
sort of hit from
each one of you on your studios and like
where you want to go in the future when
it comes to innovation
so at hazelite what we want to push all
the time
is combining the story in the gameplay
we pushed out a lot
using the mechanics more and more to try
to tell the story use the mechanics to
reflect what goes on the story
create unique cool experience that
players haven't played before
now is the time to make something
totally great and unique it's harder in
a movie today because
it's been going on for longer in a sense
it's a good time to make something great
you know from villain studios it's you
know our games have come to be
um really sort of playing as believing
uh but playing as believing
is really at the heart of creating
something new an
experience that people really think is
novel i haven't seen something like this
before
and that's what we want to keep doing at
sewing i feel like we're always looking
for new ways of delivering story and
dialogue and because it's
such a diverse industry with so many
different people and backgrounds and
and ways of thinking and working from
programmers to artists
so i think i mean that's such a huge fun
inspiring part and why i love working
with games
i was going to say we are so young as a
studio that i think
we're incredibly grateful for the fact
that we get to do
something that we really love i don't
think either of us realized how much we
were going to love
working on this game and part of that is
the unknown um to have come as far as we
have in
one year i just i'm so excited to see
where it goes yeah i feel like we do
have we do have a voice
and we're still finding our voice in the
end and we're
we're growing not only as a studio and
evolving at such a rapid pace
like pace but we're having fun while
doing it as well and i think it's about
sharing that fun and you know and
sharing our experience
our highs and lows and just being open
because again that's
you know that's also part of it right
it's about being open about sharing
thank you all for letting me pester you
with so many questions and playing along
and
i really appreciate it everyone's time
thank you thank you all so much
thank you cool thanks guys thank you
thank you so much great to be here with
all of you thank you so that was all
very thoughtful and uh very
inspirational at times
thank you for joining us more from the
ea play live spotlight series will be
coming soon
follow at ea on twitter or go to ea.com
for the latest updates on these games
and everything else from the studio
also remember that ea play live is on
july 22nd
and if you've watched this far you
definitely don't want to miss that
because there will be some exciting news
from lost and random
i'm todd martens from the los angeles
times thank you for joining us
[Music]
so
you